[Music]
[Music]
hey Arthur Arthur where would you grow
up for stuff um what doesn't what's okay
and you started with which game not
ambitious blood game what I moved over
the continent with my cousin mine my
friend died and got the game name within
me and changed him
I became how is the gang life changed
you think you know these years no no
he's not what it would back then we used
to go fight in Allen Street gonna have a
night we'll fight in rumble so be then
generation shouldn't go down this him
anybody everybody
we didn't we're not organized today
one person calling chatter so cool
now everybody wanna kosher hey buddy
wanna be a leader you can tell no one
nothing okay now give me you making sure
that it's not angle something no such
thing in you don't gonna present time
yes I am I'm good party over 37 years in
my life first time I went to gym its
game being in Sedona young continues on
like Jewish gentleman liquor store in
the same night got away nice little of
the money back in town he got away with
about six when later that's an Ayatollah
the safe three six months spending money
creep my second time the drugs healed a
third time I'm seventeen twenty brave at
home against Bodhi salsa
against the police officer attempted
murder it was barely with me yeah come
in great binding on and they try to send
me on at the time they didn't and I've
been ten years
big one after that I take for
I got could have been a monkey a guy we
can kill him I killed a guy maybe to
kill my doing good you breathe I'm done
and that's what made me get away from
being a good and lengthen a game
Dean had a mistake for me my mama my
child and it makes nothing she sent me
that time
oh well now I'm gonna kids blood day
night everybody do run
yeah McCoy
pictures of my daughter yeah we gonna
team taking my kid to spirit while I got
my
and then he caught the old lady told my
let's play please come
anyone doing I know before I grab my gun
juggler on the back leg that's not good
Kent and his man shooting at me she's in
the game code I said I got boom my main
man looks like never came sending me
Dwight
and then you're done
I think Vicki my drink I fought it like
a big bad dream
I found guilty I'm giving 26 like I
guess it was yours would you know then
don't just thinking just what you do I
think anybody really can sing I can feel
I would never get out
a real bad to anything John gangbang
giving them by the system [ __ ]
fantasies
throughout the game being lieutenants I
mean swap dancing blue bag I'm a pocket
yeah Thank You gaming do you think
it's more money so how did they get
ready my begin sir
okay I'm game you know decent their [ __ ]
my get me man just in 38 great day
don't get in Kenya and how many people
have you murdered honest I'm speaking
for ya copper the one and that one see
that's justifies anything
yeah and that's when I should shouldn't
get no time Danna
whole place in man
I guess Westerners whatever
hey Eugene where you from first I try
this mark - me again live your enemies
from this one's funny one connection
I'll give ya the old cat and my
I'm laughing
your game English and it's like I never
became universe man I wanna be feeling
why you gonna able to my ring the bell I
will never see myself and piercing
vision to my channel
son can you catch that movie gaming way
no I can't
take for customer
pedophile rapist Mitch is I saw these
crimes and your your world ugly
non-gaming and you want to debrief you
debrief you have to give up information
for lunch at calling in opinion my
opinion that your that
I don't say the violations with every
race have certain image about this and
witty said when they do you with a
[ __ ] your family and get flatter than
mine
I can't chew it nice i thirty people in
your than 30 mine three of them and
guarantee in these three I don't know
I'd love to dance you're not my crappy
look just you know I'm putting bling I
can see it now negative in you know it
really nothing
because everyone baked down with me I'm
glad to bring you back
I should put a link down let's go down
there today dude I know
which I changed a little bit more so I
thought to have something kids out there
today you know gaming wouldn't like it
nothing called mind you swish you
kidding
that
began nobody kind of missing than me
today thank you so much for sharing your
story
I appreciate this appreciate